so we just looked at two examples of
websites who use their own internal
api's to resolve new data for their
users this is really cool but unless
you're already working for a giant web
app you probably don't have a massive
internal database of cool information
you can query asynchronously but luckily
there are tons of api's available on the
web that readily serve up interesting
information and they're usually free to
use so long as you aren't making
thousands of requests per hour for
instance Google offers a ton of api's
including Google Analytics Google Maps
Google Fonts looking around the web it
isn't hard to find examples of websites
that use external api's to create
interesting interactions for users
Reddit and the reddit enhancement suite
chrome plugin interact with a few
different api is to make reddit feel
more dynamic when a user clicks on a
link that resolves to a YouTube video
reddit opens up an embedded YouTube
player which interacts with the YouTube
API or when a user opens up a link to a
Twitter feed the reddit enhancement
suite chrome plug-in fires off an ajax
request for twitter data and uses the
Twitter API to open up the tweet right
here inside the page check out the link
in the instructor notes if you want to
find some more api's that are available